My opponent tonight
co-wrote the book Lean In,
was a writer for shows
like The Simpsons
and Late Night
with David Letterman,
and has written jokes
for Barack Obama
and Hillary Clinton.
Wow, not many writers
can transition
from comedy to horror
that successfully.
-Nell Scovell. Nell, welcome.
-(cheering and applause)
Thank you for having me.
Of course. Now, I want to talk.
In this book here,
you talk a lot
about being the only
female writer in a writers' room
and helping break
the glass ceiling.
Can I just ask you
to do me a favor
before we continue?
-Y-Yeah.
-So, President Trump comes out,
he attacks Jim Comey
for his book,
-and the book
becomes a best seller. -Yeah.
-Right.
-So, I write this book.
I honestly thought
people would attack me,
and they've been so nice.
-They say it's funny.
-Sure.
-They-they love it.
-Yeah. Yeah.
Um, and it would really help
to create some controversy,
so if you wouldn't mind,
could you just call me
a no-talent whore?
Just... could you?
(cheering and applause)
Please?
(laughter)
This feels like a trap.
-I'm your guest.
-I know, exactly. This...
-I know. -Are you
Time's Upping me right now?
-Is that what's going on?
-No, no.
The problem is
throughout history
when women spoke up,
men tried to silence them.
-Uh-huh.
-And I come out with this book,
and at the one moment
when men are thinking twice
about, you know,
telling women we're terrible
and should make them sandwiches.
-See, on the one hand,
-Yeah.
like, I want to satisfy
your demand.
But I'm not always great
at satisfying women,
if I'm being quite honest
with you.
-But...
-You can do it, Jordan.
-Just...
-Nell...
I'm afraid I've looked
at your book, and you're a...
Say it.
...a-a talentless whore.
-Thank you, thank you, thank
you. -(cheering and applause)
-Was that... -I'm gonna...
Can I put that on the back?
I don't... Yes? No!
It's a great quote.
-Uh... Y-Yeah. Uh...
-All right.
-I really appreciate that.
-#YesAllMen.
(laughing)
If that can help sell
some books, please,
I know it takes a man
to sell books, so, uh,
use me however you can.
But-but in all seriousness,
uh, you are fairly talentless.
-Uh...
-Yeah.
(laughter)
-And-and unattractive
-in any way, means or form.
-Well, yeah, like...
-Yeah. -So you wrote this
all by your woman self--
is that what you're telling me?
-I, um... Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah?
Yeah? So why is it hard
to get these women
into these writers' rooms?
In fact, let me say this, you...
right now, you are trying...
one of your jobs
is to try to help get women
-into writers' rooms,
is that correct? -Yes.
-It's a mission, not a job.
But yes. -It's a mission.
Okay. Okay,
your mission is to do that.
Why-why isn't there a man doing
that thing for people like me?
Aw. Um, well,
there-there have been.
Their names are, uh,
David Letterman,
Jay Leno, Johnny Carson.
You just were born
at the wrong time, Jordan.
I-I keep saying that.
I should have been born
20 years earlier, right?
You've also written
for, uh, Hillary Clinton
and Barack Obama.
Uh, what was it like
writing for...
humor for people like that,
with no sense of humor?
(groaning, laughter)
Well, I actually disagree,
and I think President Obama,
especially,
had an incredible sense
of humor.
He had great delivery.
This... Well, I-I have...
This-this is a joke you wrote
that he did not read.
-Is that correct? -Right,
and this would be a good example
of how untalented I am.
-Great.
-Yeah.
Well, let-let... let me
read some of this then.
"I turned 50 while in office
which meant
"I had to have
my first colonoscopy,
"and guess what they found.
Mitch McConnell."
(laughter, groaning)
"That guy can obstruct
anything."
(laughing):
Yeah.
(laughter)
-I see what you're doing there.
-Yeah, yeah.
You're-you're implying
that Mitch McConnell
was up the president's ass.
Yeah, maybe that's why
he didn't do the joke.
-Yes.
-You think?
I'm gonna say that...
that I do like.
Nell, tell me something
I already know.
-Can I tell you two things?
-Please.
Okay, the first is
that your forehead takes up
as much space
as the rest of your face.
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
And...
But you knew that.
And you have more.
And-and the second is that
half of your writing staff
is female,
so... high five.
-Oh, that's-that
Viacom-mandated. -What? no.
-Uh, yeah. No, no, no, no.
-No? No?
-No, no, no, no. -Oh,
I was so proud of you, Jordan.
No, no. Oh, no.
(applause and cheering)
No. No. No, no, no, no.
Her book is called
Just the Funny Parts.
Nell Scovell.